ok première loi la guerre commence
aujourd'hui amical et que leurs
commandes
c'est un pari risqué d'adopter un
classique du cinéma québécois qui a
marqué toute une génération notamment
avec cette réplique mythique et c'est
réussi
la guerre des tuques 3d actualise sans
dénaturer l'histoire de cette bande
d'amis qui font la guerre pour tromper
l'ennui des vacances d'hiver
ainsi vous aviez gagné
la nouvelle mouture respecte le film
culte sorti en 1984 dans la foulée des
contes pour tous de rock demers réalisé
par andré melançon
le film original avait été distribué
dans plus de 125 pays et avait connu un
succès monstre
la version 2015 se donne le même mandat
rejoindre les jeunes en faisant écho à
leurs préoccupations dont l'amitié la
rivalité l'honneur et le deuil qu'à en
formule d'animation l'histoire est
forcément au moins réaliste mais
beaucoup plus spectaculaire les
batailles lefort et les décors sont plus
impressionnants que jamais les
personnages sont quant à eux plus
caricaturaux mis suffisamment attachant
pour livrer quelques moments d'émotion
l'enfance pied et c'est une valeur
ajoutée d'avoir invité des vedettes
québécoises à prêter leur voix aux
personnages
mariloup wolfe est particulièrement
efficace dans le rôle de ce chien tout
huit boy s'appelle commun cléo tout
comme nicolas savard l'herbier dans
celui du général chez paul gut à me
servir de mon clairon pour une bataille
de potton riches c'est sans compter les
voix de sophie cadieux d' hélène
bourgeois leclerc et d'andré sauvé mais
moi je te dis mon gars lui une mention
toute spéciale aussi pour la trame
sonore qui met en valeur de nombreux
artistes québécois
le film réunit non seulement ce qui est
populaire mais aussi ce qui se fait de
meilleur rendu
sans réussir à rivaliser avec le niveau
de virtuosité des studios américains
cette production québécoise tire son
épingle du jeu la guerre des tuques 3d
fait revivre la nostalgie d'autrefois
tout en amusant des enfants